you're about an hour and a half into the
movie and boy are you regretting that
large soda you can hold it
sure but should you being is pretty
important your kidneys filter excess
water and waste out of your blood and
that urine needs somewhere to go
your bladder normally it will hold one
to two cups comfortably but if you make
a habit out of holding your pee for long
periods of time you can actually stretch
your bladder to easily hold even more
one study found that nurses who often
held it in all day due to job
constraints had nearly double the normal
bladder capacity and turns out they were
totally fine but that doesn't mean that
you should hold it in if you can help it
because your bladder might not be the
only thing to stretch you may also
stretch your external sphincter muscles
those are important muscles connected to
the outside of your bladder that are the
gatekeepers of just golden liquid clench
them and you hold in the gold relax them
and you release the flood but if you
over stretch them you can actually lose
control this is rare and it usually
takes decades of holding it in too long
to reach that point but once you do it
can lead to some awkward and even
dangerous situations for example with
less overall control you risk leaking
urine when your bladder is full and not
emptying it all the way when you finally
do go not only can this increase your
need to urinate more often since your
bladder fills up quicker it can also
lead to a serious disorder called
urinary retention where you end up with
too much urine in your bladder for too
long and since your bladder is basically
a warm wet bag of body waste
it's the perfect breeding ground for
harmful bacteria that will cause all
sorts of damage
even worse if you're really unlucky and
retained too much urine it may back up
into your kidneys this can cause kidney
failure and ultimately death the good
news is you're more likely to just lose
control of your muscles and pee way
before your bladder hits this point why
not reduce the risk altogether and just
go to the bathroom okay I get it
the movie is absolutely gripping luckily
you'll be fine if you only hold it in
for a short time every once in a while
so go ahead hang in there just don't
make a habit of any other weird science
questions you have ask us in the
comments
[Music]